from it's ignorance adults to some
blatant body shaming to a handful of
dead bodies violence and innuendos that
are hard to ignore The Goonies features
story components that made no sense for
the young audience the movie was geared
towards here are things only adults
notice about the Goonies The Goonies
doesn't waste any time in grabbing your
attention in the film's opening seconds
viewers bear witness to the unfortunate
scene of a prisoner hanging in the
county jail as an officer releases the
inmates for lunch
turns out the joke was on that cop and
us the prisoner is Jake Fratelli
and he lures the cop in only to reveal
he wasn't actually dead with a wry smile
Jake clobbers the man and unhooks
himself from the makeshift noose he
created with his brother Francis pouring
gasoline all around the building and
mama waiting in the getaway car things
are kicked off as Jake emerges donning a
scarf and Fedora for good measure
because really what's the point of
conducting the perfect getaway if you
can't do it decked out your Sunday best
needless to say this introduction is
necessary in painting the Fratellis as a
gang to be reckoned with but between
Jake's fake out and Francis's taste for
setting fire to things this sure was a
jarring way to begin a kid's movie
Lawrence chunk Cohen is one of the
members of the Goonies chunk is an
unfortunate nickname for sure and one
that is perpetuated throughout the film
what were the kids love of ice cream and
pizza after the jailbreak a chaotic
police chase ensues and wouldn't you
know it chunk witnesses the whole thing
instead of listening to his story though
fellow goony mouth forces the kid to do
the embarrassing truffle shuffle in
order to grant him entry to the house
but this sort of fat shaming wouldn't
fly today Richard Donner told Uproxx in
2015 so much humor comes from pain
although I'm sure he was too young to be
analytical about it but I'm sure that
was part of his instincts it was a
painful scene painful or not that scene
really painted a picture as to who chunk
was he ended up spending most of the
film separated from the group leading to
the inevitable relationship he created
with sloth from being a prisoner to the
Fratellis to making friends with sloth
the movie ends with chunk inviting the
seven-foot tall emotionally challenged
stranger to live in his house he doesn't
consult his parents or consider the
logistics of fitting this giant dude
into the bathtub that couch or his
bedroom chunk doesn't pay his parents
mortgage but he's paid the price of life
apparently that's enough
after Mikey finds an old map in the
Attic the group with the help of mouths
impeccable Spanish speaking skills
translate the message and ponder the
mythical legend of the pirate known
simply as one-eyed Willy my dad can use
this discovery is the inspiration behind
the whole crazy adventure the kids go on
not only was there allegedly riches on
the Pirates elusive ship this treasure
hunt was a symbol of their last summer
together for the movies to our iteration
the Goonies are put through the
proverbial wringer they're chased by
armed criminals dodge booby traps and
overcome physical challenges all in the
name of the buried treasure that awaits
them and while the hunt for one-eyed
Willy proves fruitful in the end the
kids came out on top while the Fratellis
pay the price
no one ever acknowledges the big
elephant in the room one-eyed Willy is
totally a euphemism for male genitals
the kids set off to do their Goonies
thing leaving Mikey's big brother brand
all tied up that doesn't stop him for
long to catch up to the gang he takes
extreme measures which includes
hijacking a young girl's bicycle scene
Josh Brolin pedaled for his life on this
tiny thing was a surefire lap getter but
you can't ignore the simple fact that
the dude stole a little kids property
the only thing that really justifies the
crime is the inevitable payoff that's
sure to follow with theft under his belt
brand hustles down the road to catch up
with his brother's crew but instead of
keeping the kids out of trouble Brandis
suddenly faced with trouble of his own
choice car the bully rolls up on brand
with Andi riding shotgun in the flashy
convertible
after a short back-and-forth Troy plays
a prank on Brandt holding him as the car
accelerates the speed gets the best of
brand sending the bike and him over a
cliff to imminent doom below but
miraculously brand doesn't suffer
injuries or die soon after his
death-defying stunt
Mikey's brother shows up outside the
pretend I died with a dirty face and not
a scratch on him while on their journey
Mikey eventually catches up with the
remains of treasure hunter Chester
copperpot we're introduced to his story
through a 1930s newspaper article that
announces his disappearance after
searching for one-eyed Willy's treasure
it turns out copperpot activated a booby
trap which led to his untimely death but
instead of alerting the authorities at
the body of a man who's been
seen and presumed dead for nearly five
decades has been found the kids decide
to take matters into their own hands and
loot the man's body there's something to
be said for respecting the dead
however in the Goonies where the hunt
for the treasure is the end-all be-all
of the entire film these matters end up
being quite trivial there's a good
portion of the Goonies that finds our
heroes and tunnels underneath the city
of Astoria as ancient as this
underground maze feels it's hard not to
notice the modern-day pipes that can be
seen adorning the walls the kids pass
this isn't a sewer or anything but it
kind of is
we're now roughly at the film's halfway
point and it's an integral part of the
story
do the kids continue on their mission of
finding one-eyed Willy or do they bail
to the warm beds awaiting them above
ground this conundrum comes to a head
once Mikey and the gang come across the
wishing well in town which happens to
connect with the tunnel they're lost in
it also happens to reconnect Steph and
Ian brand with Troy aside from the fact
that he's conveniently hanging with his
buds at the well this moment marks a
fork in the road for the gang do they
return to the adult world by taking a
ride in Troy's bucket we all know how
this ends up but what's the deal with
the bucket being the only option to save
the kids from the cold wet bowels of the
city let's remember there were
modern-day pipes on the tunnel wall so
obviously there had to be a ladder
somewhere right
this whole Goonies adventure began with
the solid reality that Mikey and brand
would be moving due to their houses
pending foreclosure weekend as
fantastical as it was the climax tied up
every loose end in one baffling sequence
after the kids escape one-eyed Willie's
ship alive they arrive on the town's
beach where conveniently enough their
parents the police and the press are
waiting as the kids are reunited with
their families
Troy shows up with his wealthy father
the guy out to buy the Walsh family's
home aside from wondering how they all
knew to come to this Beach at the same
time you have to appreciate the audacity
of Troy's dad as families are reunited
and the kids are proven to be safe or
closure paperwork is handed to Mike's
dad and he almost signs it right there
on the beach thanks to mrs. Walsh's made
Rosalita all is fixed checking the
pockets of one of the kids jackets she
finds a bunch of jewels suddenly
everybody buys into the one-eyed Willie
myth Mikey's father makes an immediate
decision to rip up the foreclosure
paperwork announcing they'll never sell
the house ever that's all well and good
but these are jewels found in a kid's
pocket it probably would have been a
good decision to have them appraised
first right
but right now they gotta do what's right
for them
their time their time up there down here
it's our time
Mikey's impassioned speech in the
tunnels encapsulates the whole film much
like other 80s kid centric stories the
role of adults were pretty ancillary
here that's all well and good but what
happens when a group of children goes
missing in a small town such as this
we'd assume there'd be some sort of
uproar and yet the only people who get a
slap on the wrist or the Fratellis like
any great film The Goonies suspends our
disbelief from start to finish that's
what we love about the classic but let's
be real here
a group of unruly kids acting like Mikey
and his friends would result in some
sort of punishment we're pretty sure no
one got grounded and with the press and
police crowding the beach at the movies
end one has to wonder did the Goonies
ever go into therapy after all they had
multiple run-ins with death did the
police debrief them after they found
those dead bodies and where's Child
Protective Services on all this the 80s
man what a weird time to be alive while
The Fratellis are the primary villains
of The Goonies
Troy Perkins gives them a run for their
money in the bad guy department he's the
very ideal of an 80s youth movie villain
a rich arrogant jerk jock who resents
poor people and constantly aligns
himself with his powerful father he's
even spotted wearing country club
clothes and a visor the very uniform of
reagan-era filmdom villainy adding
another level of awfulness detroy and
beyond the obvious signifiers noticeable
by even the youngest viewers he's a
predator likely used to getting whatever
he wants whenever he wants it troy leers
at makes plays for and all that stalk
sandy throughout the Goonies kids
watching probably won't understand when
he utilizes a car's rear view mirror to
attempt to sneak a creepy peek up Andy
skirt he laughs at her when she tells
him to stop andy leider casually
mentions that Troy's been looking down
her shirt and just before he discovers
The Goonies in the well Troy brags to
his friends about his future plans with
her I put it this way I didn't make it
with her yet and I stress yet
that's a euphemism delivered in an
alarming and deeply off-putting way The
Goonies gets more than just one happy
ending of the goon squad evading the
Fratellis reuniting with their parents
avoiding foreclosure and uncovering the
coolest pirate ship in movie history
there's also the matter of sloth the
third Fratelli kid initially considered
a monstrous villain he's redeemed when
chunk provides contact from a decent
human being attention and a Baby Ruth
the kids watching the movie sloth was
misunderstood or a bad guy turned into a
good guy adults will notice the lead up
to sloths redemption he was the victim
of some deplorable acts of abuse what
audiences first catch a glimpse of sloth
he's chained up and his brother Jake is
torturing him with his singing his
family in prison sim purposely upsets
him and then leaves him all alone with
food tantalizingly out of reach that The
Fratellis purposely star sloth is made
apparent both when he rips his chains
off the wall to get to chunks Baby Ruth
and when he helps himself to the ice
cream in the freezer while chunk is on
the phone from the beginning of the film
audiences were dealt a bunch of visuals
that showed how dangerous of a force the
Fratellis work and once the kids meet
the crime family it's revealed they'll
stop at nothing to find one-eyed
Willie's treasure as well armed with
knives guns and even at one point a
sword The Fratellis prove themselves to
be a ruthless gang of Outlaws as
dangerous as they were though it seems
that our team of young heroes were
quicker and smarter time and again the
Goonies found themselves steps ahead of
the criminals until they finally faced
them in the climactic fight on one-eyed
Willy ship cornered the kids were
running out of options and then data
stepped up with his odd gadgets and
glorious gumption swords and guns were
no match for the kids utility belts
which eventually took down the crime
family a fighting mechanism to Francis's
crotch was the beginning of the Fratelli
family's downfall science and innovation
proved themselves to be the ultimate
weapons here after all this is a Goonies
world and we're just living in it check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]